اذا وصلنا لفقره مع وضد في مصر وبين مؤيد
ومعارض موضوع يثير الجدل حول ما يطلق
عليهن اعلاميا فتيات التيك توك الفتيات
يواجهن حكما واحكاما وعقوبات مغلظه تندرج
تحت مسمى قانون مكافحه الجرائم
الالكترونيه تشتد العقوبه بالاعتداء على
المبادئ او القيم الاسريه هناك من يرى
ضروره لانقاذ هؤلاء الفتيات مقيما دعوه
تطالب بالغاء او مقيما دعوات تطالب بالغاء
وتجميد ماده القيم الاسريه معتبرها فضفاضه
الاخرون او الطرف الاخر يشدد على ضروره
وجود مثل هذه القوانين المزيد من التفاصيل
حول بدايه ازمه القانون في مصر مع ندى
حجازي ندى
هل تتذكرون حنين حسام ومواد الادهم وانضمت
لهما مؤخرا سلمى الشيمي فتيات التيك توك
او هكذا اصبحت اسماؤهن في وسائل الاعلام
في القضايا التي نصبت لهن ولمثل هن من
الفتيات في السجن بتهمه التعديه على قيم
الاسره المصريه احنا لازم بقى نشيل التيك
توك ونشيل السوشيال ميديا من حياتنا شويه
يا جماعه والله الدنيا زمان كانت لطيفه من
غير سوشيال ميديا لان احنا بنستغلها غلط
لكن احنا طالما في زمن حتى لو انت حافظت
في مكان طب ما انا هطلع لك من مكان تاني
القيم الاسريه هو مصطلح في الفاظ يمثل
الذوق العام في الجدل بحسب الدعوه التي
تطالب بتجميد او الغاء المواد القانونيه
التي حبسنا بسببها من بينما تنص عليه هذه
المواد هي معاقبه من ينشر صورا ومقاطع
فيديو خادشه للحياء بالسجن او تتضمن
اغراءات وفجورا على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي هذه مواد حسب الدعوه القانونيه
ظلمت الفتيات المسجونات لان الرقص فن مصري
راسخ في المجتمع على اي حال وفي كل مكان
وزمان سواء عبر شاشات التلفزيون والتراث
السينمائي الذي يخضع لرقابه المصنفات
طبعا لا مش
مش مضبوط
كتير يا رب تتاثر بالموضوع دوت في اطفال
وكده كمان بتشوف الحاجات ديت فما ينفعش
اصلا فلازم الماده تكون موجوده لكن الدعوه
المطالبه بالغاء ماده التعدي على القيم
الاسريه تلقى اعتراضا ممن يعتبر انها تحفظ
عادات وتقاليد لطالما تمسك بها المجتمع
وان الغائها او تجميدها قد يؤدي الى نوع
من الخروج عن قيم المجتمع بل وربما
الانحلال في نظر البعض وفي كل الاحوال
اخذت هذه القضيه لتضاف الى الجدل القديمه
الجديد جدل تسليم الرايه بين اجيال تؤمن
بالقديم وثوابته واجيال جديده تبحث عن
التجديد او في نظرها المزيد من الحريه
وانتم مع من تتفقون
نرحب بضيوفنا مشاهدينا من القاهره الدكتور
هاني سامح المحامي والحقوق وصاحب الدعوه
القضائيه بالغاء ماده القيم الاسريه من
القانون نرحب ايضا بمحمود البدوي المحامي
بالنقد وضد الغاء ماده القيم الاسريه من
القانون اهلا بكم معنا في صباح العربيه
سابدا معك دكتور هاني بدايه ماده في
القانون المصري معمول بها منذ سنوات لماذا
الان قررت انك ترفع دعوه لالغاء هذه
الماده بدعوه او بحجه انها فضفاضه
لانها تستغل يا فندم من قبل طيور الظلام
ومن قبل اصحاب القيم الاسلامويه الرجعيه
هذه الماده للاسفاء استخدامها
لاصدار اتهامات تعود بنا الى عصور القرون
الوسطى الى عصور المحاكم التفتيش يتم
التنكيل بفتيات لاجل لا شيء الفتيات ما
بيعملوش حاجه غير انهم يعني بيقلدوا الفن
والتراث المصري الاصيل بيقلده ما يشاهدوه
على قنوات ماسبيرو يقلده ما يشاهدوه في
الافلام التراثيه المصريه اللي كل الشعب
بيفخر بها وبيحبها فطبعا للاسف يتم
استغلال هذه الماده يعني تتحدث عن هذا
المحتوى للبنات بينشروه معناته انت موافق
عليه
لانه لا شيء سوى
انعكاس لتراث مصري عريق
بكل تاكيد يعني كلها الفتيات ما بيعملوش
حاجه لو شاهدنا لو جبنا قنوات التلفزيون
الحكومي نفس الشيء طيب يعني عندنا
الفنانات المصريات الرائعات برضو بيعملوا
كانوا بيعملوا نفس هذه الحركات نفس هذه
الملابس هقول لحضرتك على حاجه احنا هنروح
بعيد ليه للاسف هذه القيم المزعومه هي
طبعا قيم فضفاضه احنا مش عارفين هل هي قيم
الاسلامويين ولا قيم السلفيين ولا قيم
الرجعيين ولا قيم مصر الستينات ولا قيم
مصر في السبعينات ولا قيم الطبقات الراقيه
في المنتجعات المصريه قيم الساحل الشمالي
ولا قيمه شرم الشيخ خلينا نسمع استغلالها
للتنكيل بالفتيات دكتور هاني خلينا نسمع
الاستاذ محمود البدوي استاذ محمود شايفك
بتضحك ليه تحياتي يا فندم صباح الخير اهلا
اكيد لان للاسف الشديد مؤخرا احنا
ابتولينا ابتولينا بعدد من الدعاوى اللي
هي بتنم عن بفلسفه القانون وفلسفه التشريع
وان كمان يعني سالني ان انا اسمع في حديث
ضيفك الكريم بتوجه اليه طبعا بالتحيه ان
هو بيعمل عمليه قياس خاطئ على ان ما يقدم
من خلال قنوات التيك توك او بعض القنوات
الخاصه على التيك توك وبعض الامور اللي
خرجت علينا وهي هجينه على المجتمع ودخيل
على المجتمع بيقيسها بالفن المصري القديم
اللي هو يعني
الدكتور هاني بيقول هي موجوده احنا يعني
لماذا نكون مثل النعامه في الرؤوس لا
اجادل في ان الرقص موجود لا اجدد في ان
رقص موجود ولا اجادل في دور الفن في
الارتقاء بالاخلاق والذوق في المجتمع
المصري ولكن خليني اتكلم عن الفن المسؤول
الفن الذي يحافظ على القيم مش النهارده
اللي كان فيه واحده فيه بتتكلم بتقول
سريرك مسرحك وتكشف الدعاوى وتكشف
التحقيقات النيابه العامه الموقره عن ان
الامر كان على تماس مع جريمه استغلال
البشر والاتجار بالبشر بهذا امر مرفوض
وهذا قياس خاطئ
الفهم مغلوط لوقائع هذه الدعوه طب هو لب
الموضوع
فضفاضت التعريف او انه هذا التعريف لما
يخدش القيم الاسريه فضفاض وغير واضح طب
اليس من الاجدى ان نبدا هنا يعني بالقانون
عاده بيكون في ملاحق وملحق يفسر ويعرف كل
مصطلح يرد في اي نص قانوني ليه ما في بهذا
القانون شيء كذلك
احنا اتكلمنا هنا او الماده هنا بتتكلم عن
القيم الاخلاقيه وخليني اقول لحضرتك ان
القيمه المجتمعيه ربما تكون مختلفه من
مكان لمكان ولكن انا معك في ان الماده
ربما تكون فضفاضه ومش موضحه الامر على وجه
مفسر ولكن خليني اقول لحضرتك النهارده ان
انا عندي ضمانتين حقيقيتين بيضمنوا عدم
اختصار استخدام هذه الماده ضد اي حد عندي
ضمانات التحقيقات التي تجريها النيابه
العامه للنقره وهي من تدافع عن حقوق
المجتمع وكمان حتى لو النيابه قدمت لايحه
بادله الاتهام عندي القضاء المصري المحترم
بيشوف ما تم تقديمه من ادله التهام وكمان
مسقوا مسقه دفاع المتهمين من وقائع ويقيم
العدل ما بين الطرفين واضح خليني كمان في
عجاله بسيطه يعني خليني اعطي خليني اعطي
الدكتور هاني اذا تكرمت استاذ محمود من
قبل 2400 سنه قبل الدكتور
اه عندنا احكام قضاء عندنا احكام قضائيه
كثيره صدرت بتنتهك حقوق المراه عندنا
احكام قضائيه كثيره صدر المراه خلينا
خلينا نجاوب خلينا نجاوب على مقاله
الاستاذ ضحى خلينا نجاوب دكتور هاني خلينا
نجاوب على ما قاله قال بانه استغلال التيك
توك الى الاتجار بالبشر
غير صحيحه يا فندم عندنا نيابه النقد ردت
على هذا الادعاء جريمه الاتجار بالبشر
جريمه خطيره جدا والحداثه والتنوير هو
الاصدر هذه الجريمه ولكن القيم الرجعيه
كانت بتاصل العبوديه وبتاصل تجرب البشر
البنات ما عملوش حاجه غير انهم ظهروا على
شاشات التيك توك
ظهور هذا تم توصيفه بانه تجارب البشر وهذا
غير صحيح ونيابه اني اقدر ردت رد وافي
المساله طيب شكرا جزيلا الدكتور هاني سامح
المحامي والحقوقي وصاحب الدعوه القضائيه
بالغاء ماده القيم الاسريه من القانون
ايضا الشكر الموصول لمحمود الاستاذ محمود
البدوي المحامي بالنقضه وضد الغاء ماده
القيم الاسريه من هذا القانون شكرا جزيلا
لكم لمتابعه
المزيد والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على
زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات